France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'Europe cette semaine les 27
regardent du côté de l'Ukraine et
au-delà mais que se passe-t-il vraiment
en Russie à la suite de la mutinerie du
groupe Wagner contre le régime de
Vladimir Poutine les interrogations et
les spéculations vont bons trains
quelles conséquence géopolitique sur la
guerre quels efforts diplomatiques et de
défense doivent déployer les Européens
en conséquence nous en parlons tout de
suite avec le chef des ambassadeurs
européens l'Italien Stefano sanino
bonjour vous êtes en fait le secrétaire
général du service d'action extérieure
vous avez été d'ailleurs vous-même de
nombreuses fois ambassadeurs dans plein
de régions du monde et vous suivez bien
sûr cette actualité de la guerre à nos
portes de près quelle est l'analyse de
vos ambassadeurs sur ce qui s'est passé
en Russie
c'était essentiellement il avait un
problème avec leadship militaire en
Russie il voulait dissoudre bonne
qualité le groupe Wagner et intégrer
dans le système militaire et il a décidé
que ça c'est quelque chose qui ne
pouvait pas accepter et donc il a
commencé une marche sur le pour la
liberté comme elle a dit qui est
peut-être qu'il ne pensait pas qu'il
pouvait avoir tant de succès et arriver
tout près de Moscou peut-être qu'il a
aussi assez préoccupé des conséquences
c'est que tout ça pouvait avoir et donc
on a vu la fin de l'histoire la décision
de retourner sur ses pas et
l'intervention du président Lucky
chewingo et le retour dans sur ces
positions mais ce qui est intéressant je
crois de souligner dans cette dans cette
histoire un peu bizarre effectivement
c'est que il y a une leadership un
Moscou qui est évidemment très
énormément affaibli pour la première
fois il y a vraiment un défi qui est
fait à la leadership
le président et lui-même affaibli
quelque sorte il a dû aussi faire
recours à médiateur externe pour pouvoir
résoudre cette question la lui revenir
aussi sous ses propres positions en
disant que c'était un acceptable
privilégié
[Musique]
donc il y a certainement un impact très
très fort sur ce qui est la leadshiprus
dans un moment aussi très délicat de la
confrontation et du conflit en Ukraine
dans un moment où nous nous augmentons
notre facilité pour la paix de 3,5
milliards d'euros on a déjà alloué pour
rappel aux Ukrainiens
6,4,6 milliards depuis le début du
conflit est-ce que ça ça peut faire la
différence je crois qu'il y a une chose
qui est certaine et que tous les États
membres tous les 27 on dit que dans
cette dans ce moment particulier il
faudra redoubler les pourra de soutien à
l'Ukraine et ça c'est un message
univoque et donc la partie militaire
évidemment une impertie importante donc
le fait qu'on est on était on est tombé
d'accord pour augmenter encore la
facilité des pays de 3,5 milliards c'est
quelque chose de très important je
voudrais souligner une chose qui je
crois que c'est important la facilité de
paix à une capacité de regarder un peu
tout le monde donc c'est évidemment
l'Ukraine maintenant est en train
d'absorber beaucoup de ses capacités
mais on n'a pas oublié les autres
régions du monde on n'a pas oublié
l'Afrique on n'a pas oublié les Balkans
on n'a pas oublié les Moyen-Orient ou on
continue à déployer nos efforts on va en
parler au sein des 27 il y a quand même
des voies un peu dissonantes toujours un
peu la Hongrie d'ailleurs qui tente de
bloquer les aides à l'Ukraine tant que
que ces banques angoisses sont sur la
liste des sponsors de guerre est-ce
qu'on a un problème de veto diplomatique
de la Hongrie de Victor urban une fois
de la Pologne de droits et justice et
puis finalement qui qui nous empêche de
faire la diplomatie la plus efficace
il y a ce sont des mesures des gens que
ceux qui sont basés sur la sur la base
d'une autre été sur une
unité donc il doit être votés par tous
les 27 États membres et évidemment il
faut faire un effort pour convaincre
tout le monde de voter en faveur de ses
propositions
maintenant c'est vrai qu'il y a une
question qui se pose sur un site sur
laquelle les autorités ukrainiennes ont
aussi mis un certain nombre
d'entreprises européennes il inclut la
banque à cette banque angouloise et on
est en train de travailler soit en
bilatéral avec les pays qui sont
directement concernés soit nous pour
essayer de trouver une solution et pour
essayer d'aller directement avec la
huitième tranche de la de l'assistance
militaire
justement assistance militaire mais
aussi
réflexion et le dernier sommet du 29 et
30 juin là encore démontré sur
l'implication d'un élargissement de
l'Union européenne en particulier à
l'Ukraine avec un rapport oral de la
Commission européenne on sait qu'il y a
encore de graves problèmes de corruption
est-ce que il faut donner des signaux si
positifs il y a eu un premier rapport
vous l'avez dit un premier rapport de la
commission sous les sectes sur cette
critères on appelle seven steps les pas
que
l'Ukraine doit faire pour s'approcher à
l'Union européenne il y a déjà deux qui
sont conseillés complets sur tous les
autres il y a
appréciation positive pour les efforts
qui ont été faits évidemment l'élément
de la lutte contre la corruption c'est
très important ça a aussi très important
qui puisse avoir pour avoir
mécanisme de soutien à la reconstruction
de l'Ukraine et c'est pour cela que le
processus d'élargissement peut être très
utile pour aussi pour résoudre ce type
de problème
il y a encore de du temps devant nous en
octobre en deuxième rapport cette fois
un rapport écrit de la Commission sur
l'état d'avancement de la
haie les Pays-Bas donc l'Allemagne est
un petit peu la France aussi se demande
si s'il est opportun d'ouvrir finalement
ses négociations à la fin de l'année
avec avec un pays comme l'Ukraine en
pleine guerre je ne sais même très
honnêtement je peux être une lecture un
peu plus positive elle a des latitudes
des capitales évidemment on ne peut
l'occuper en disant c'est un processus
qui ne peut pas avoir seulement une
connotation politique il faut aussi voir
quels sont la quelle est la situation
dans laquelle les pays se trouve mais
c'est vrai aussi que
l'Ukraine en considération du fait que
un en guerre a fait des énormes efforts
dans cette direction donc moi il faut
être patient il faut attendre jusqu'à à
la fin de l'année pour voir quel sera
l'évaluation de la des États membres je
ne suis pas si négatif sur la pression
qui est donnée par les États membres et
mettez-moi d'ajouter
la mole de vie est aussi dans la ligne
parce que c'est important de ne pas
l'oublier et on veut essayer de voir
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire aussi avec la
géologie qui est un pays en retard
puisqu'elle n'a pas obtenu la
candidature le statut de candidat mais
on veut pas oublier alors les chefs de
la diplomatie des États baltes étaient
réunis cette semaine à Paris très
inquiet de l'insurrection de ce groupe
Wagner et de la présence de ces soldats
en Biélorussie désormais j'ai interviewé
le ministre des Affaires étrangères de
Lettonie Edgar
qui sera d'ailleurs le prochain
président les tons dans quelques
semaines on l'écoute
il semblerait que le pouvoir du
président Poutine soit affaibli
une autre chose est assez flou
entre le Kremlin
et Monsieur Prigogine
ce que nous regardons avec attention
c'est l'annonce qu'une partie du groupe
Wagner est en train de déménager en
Biélorussie
tout comme Monsieur Prigogine
et des pays voisins
c'est un défi sécurité que nous devons
prendre très au sérieux car nous ne
voulons pas du groupe Wagner si près de
notre frontière parce que vous êtes donc
la Lettonie ce pays de 2 millions
d'habitants qui est voisin de la
Biélorussie et en effet vous avez des
motifs d'inquiétude de l'arrivée de ces
troupes wagnères qui pourraient
d'ailleurs ouvrir aussi un autre front
pour les Ukrainiens au nord et proche de
exactement je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec votre analyse je pense que pour
l'instant ce plan est complètement flou
c'est très étrange car il y a trois ans
les autorités biélorus sont arrêtées
plus de 30 mercenaires du groupe Wagner
et les ont accusés de comploter contre
Monsieur lucaschenko
c'était avant les élections biélorusse
polémiques d'août 2020
pourquoi et comment ces mercenaires
sont-ils accueillis en Biélorussie et
monsieur lucaschenko ne devrait-il pas
tirer des leçons des erreurs de Monsieur
Poutine c'est une grande question pour
moi donc vous êtes aussi un pays
frontalier de la Russie la lotonie a
décidé de ne plus laisser entrer les
Russes sur son territoire après la
déclenchement de de la rébellion du
groupe Wagner pourquoi justement cette
décision est-ce qu'elle va se prolonger
ce que nous avons fait depuis septembre
et c'est une décision régionale c'est
que nous n'autorisons pas les citoyens
russes munis de visa Schengen a traversé
la frontière russe ou biélorus comme
l'ont fait l'Estonie la Lituanie ainsi
que la Finlande et la Pologne qui ont la
même politique d'une certaine mesure
ce que nous disions spécifiquement c'est
que comme les efforts de mobilisation de
l'année dernière
cette mutinerie militaire que nous avons
vu nous inquiéter
certains ont parlé de coûts
qualifiés de soulèvement militaires
c'est nous verrons comment cela sera
classifié au cours des prochains jours
et semaines
mais cela ne justifie pas non plus
d'accepter des personnes sous prétexte
qu'elle fuirait la persécution des
autorités russes surtout pas ces
mercenaires du groupe Wagner
en justice car nous estimons que tous
ces mercenaires ont participé au crime
de guerre commis par le groupe Wagner en
Ukraine
voilà Stéphanie sanino l'Union
européenne qui
s'interroge et les pays baltes en
particulier effectivement sur le rôle
que vient jouer maintenant la
Biélorussie et les soldats de Wagner qui
sont qui vont être sur le accueilli sur
le sol biélorus certains ces pays baltes
préconisent par exemple qu'on applique
aussi des sanctions à la Biélorussie et
ce qu'elle peut être considérée comme
kobelligérantes à ce stade
je crois que c'est très correct la
préoccupation a exprimée par le ministre
fait l'étranger futur président de la
Lettonie sur la menace extensible
existentielle pour un particulier pour
pour les Pays Basque deuxième chose on
verra qu'il sera l'impact ici
effectivement
il y aura une capacité de
structurer une force militaire de Wagner
éventuellement dans les dans ce rôle la
Biélorussie est déjà sous sanction il
faut le rappeler depuis déjà pas mal de
temps les sanctions ont été imposées à
la Biélorussie à l'époque dans laquelle
l'allocation quoi a volé les élections
je crois que dans les prochains jours et
semaines ont
imposer un corps de lecture sanction à
la Biélorussie le chef de la diplomatie
chinoise auprès de l'UE vient de dire
que son pays n'était pas forcément
opposé à la restitution de la Crimée
dans un règlement de paix effectivement
mais il y a eu des voies dissautes sur
ce sujet en particulier de personnalité
chinoises est-ce qu'on peut faire de la
Chine un allié sur l'Ukraine une espèce
de réalisme qui doit nous conduire dans
notre action politique et diplomatique
je crois que la Chine
peut jouer un rôle évidemment c'est un
très grand pays c'est une puissance
mondiale c'est un même permanent du
Conseil de sécurité donc peut jouer un
rôle c'est vrai aussi que la Chine a mis
sous la table un certain nombre de 36
qui ne sont pas un plan de paix il faut
être aussi clair ce sont des principes
générales qui sont aussi est utile il
faut aussi souligner que
il y a quelques jours
les les
Ukrainiens ont tenu à Copenhague une
réunion très importante des des
consignes pour la sécurité nationale pas
seulement des pays du je sais mais aussi
dans un certain nombre de pays
du G13 je vends donc et
entre ça il y avait le Brésil Arabie
Saoudite
donc il y avait un certain nombre de
pays qui peuvent et doivent aussi jouer
un rôle l'Afrique du Sud qui doivent
jouer un rôle dans ce contexte
malheureusement il n'y avait pas le
représentants chinois ça c'est dommage
mais c'est intéressant que les
Ukrainiens prennent l'initiative pour
rassembler en consensus large autour des
principes du plan de paix que le
président des hélice qui est mis sur la
table
les Européens aussi veulent finalement
rallier un maximum de voix à cette cause
et en particulier on pense au pays
africains c'est encore alors là on
parlait de des bloqueurs de dans le dans
le concert des 27 la Pologne qui bloque
un accord préférentiel pour les pays
africains
Cotonou justement est-ce qu'on sait
mettre dans notre poche en quelque sorte
de notre côté diplomatiquement ces pays
africains puisque on les laisse livrer
finalement à l'influence chinoise
réduit notre assistante c'est notre
attention à ces pays ça c'est quelque
chose que je vais souligner c'est vrai
qu'on a augmenté beaucoup notre
assistance à l'Ukraine mais ça c'est
fait indépendamment de ce qu'on avait
déjà prévu pour pour les pays de
l'Afrique et on continue à le faire et
au contraire on a augmenté notre
engagement avec ce programme qui
s'appelle global Gateway et qui essaye
de mobiliser des ressources soit le
secteur public et du secteur privé sur
des grands projets de développement
économique pour les pays africains donc
je crois qu'il y a une attention qui est
très très forte à tous les pays
africains parce que on veut pas perdre
pas seulement notre influence mais les
partenariats qu'on a bâti avec ce pays
dans le temps et ça c'est quelque chose
sur laquelle j'insiste aussi c'est un
partenariat entre Go c'est pas une
laisse tout simplement de l'assistante
qu'on donne à des pays pauvres Merci à
VOUS Stéphane haussanino d'avoir été
notre invité aujourd'hui merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis on continue sur cette
question de l'Ukraine et en particulier
de la défense avec des initiatives
françaises et allemandes à couteau tiré
sur ce secteur on en parle dans notre
débat au Parlement européen en compagnie
publique Sénat
[Musique]
merci à vous de nous rejoindre depuis le
Parlement européen à Bruxelles la guerre
en Ukraine a révélé les faiblesses des
questions de sécurité pour l'Union
européenne mais pour l'heure les 27 ont
du mal à s'accorder sur une réponse
commune de défense c'est d'ailleurs le
sujet qui empoisonne la relation
Francoise allemande pour ce qui est des
questions de défense Berlin s'est
tournée vers Israël et les États-Unis
pour la mise en place d'un bouclier
anti-aérien Campari souhaite elle donner
la priorité aux achats de matériel
produits dans l'Union européenne et donc
deux clans sont en train de voir le jour
derrière l'Allemagne 16 pays membres
dont les États baltes et la plupart des
États d'Europe centrale aux côtés de la
France l'Italie l'Espagne le Portugal et
la Pologne le rêve d'Europe de la
défense caressé par le président
français Emmanuel Macron semble avoir du
plomb dans l'aile même s'il faut bien le
reconnaître la menace russe a donné une
nouvelle dynamique à cette réflexion
stratégique la Commission européenne
d'annoncer 832 millions d'euros pour
financer 41 projets communs de recherche
et développement en matière de défense
alors faut-il construire une défense
vraiment européenne de bout en bout nous
allons poser la question à nos deux
invités aujourd'hui deux membres de la
commission des affaires étrangères ici
au Parlement européen et aussi de la
sous-commission sécurité et défense
alors
zeliana zoo vous êtes député européenne
croate mais je précise que votre pays ex
communiste lui n'a pas vraiment choisi
son camp entre les deux options à
l'initiative allemande et la volonté de
Paris en revanche Emmanuel Macron on le
disait pour la France est à la manœuvre
pour imposer plutôt sa vision de
l'Europe de la défense et nous en
parlerons aussi avec vous Mounir saturi
vous êtes député européen pour les Verts
merci d'être avec nous et alors on va
commencer
nous oblige-t-elle selon vous à
réinventer très vite
ce système de défense européen la
réponse est clairement oui et d'ailleurs
dans une certaine mesure la guerre de la
Russie contre l'Ukraine a fait bouger
les lignes sur la question de la défense
on a déjà appris
en tout cas ça nous a pas laissé
insensible ça nous interroge jamais moi
je suis parlementaire depuis 2019 je
m'intéresse à l'Europe depuis longtemps
jamais le débats et les passions autour
de la robe de la défense ont été aussi
importants et en vérité les désaccords
les divergences qui a aujourd'hui entre
l'Allemagne et la France ne sont pas
mises aujourd'hui depuis longtemps
l'Allemagne et la France n'ont pas la
même approche alors la guerre a fait
bouger la position allemande qui
s'intéresse beaucoup plus à ces
questions de défense mais il faut
reconnaître que l'Allemagne qui a
toujours eu un mouvement 2% de son PIB
désormais complètement c'est historique
vous m'auriez posé la question il y a un
an j'aurais répondu que je n'y croyais
pas
mais l'Allemagne a toujours eu un
tropisme transatlantique l'Allemagne a
toujours cru pour sa défense sans doute
un héritage de l'histoire à l'OTAN
tandis que la France a souvent porté
l'idée d'une défense européenne et alors
justement madame zavesko va expliquer
l'Allemagne a lancé au sein de l'OTAN
justement de l'Alliance atlantique un
bouclier du sel European skyfield un
bouclier
anti-missiles européens mais qui se
fournit auprès des Américains pour la
moyenne portée et des Israéliens pour
les missings missiles de longue portée
pourquoi
pourquoi je ne peux pas répondre à la
question pourquoi ils ont ils ont
proposé cette idée cette position qu'il
faut faire quelque chose en commun pour
se protéger trop vite pour se précipiter
dans la protection parce que la
construction je trouve que ça c'était
idée derrière
cette initiative allemande mais on est
dans un moment quand on passe la guerre
quand on passe la l'agression de la
Russie
Ukraine tout le monde c'est se réveiller
tout d'un coup parce que allemand on n'a
pas investi rien dans sa défense mais à
l'autre côté la France avait toujours eu
une rôle très importante
par exemple
européenne et était aussi et c'est la
seule pays qui qui a nos qualités cette
situation nous
qui protège ou européenne au cas où on a
cette menace mais dans le moment quand
l'aliment qui n'était pas préparé vous
vous souvenez très bien de la débattre
comment combien il faut envoyer comme
aide à nous créer et quel est
l'équipement que l'Allemagne possède et
avance discussion avec l'ancien
président américain sur sur
l'augmentation de de budget pour la
défense tout d'un coup ils sont
réveillés ils ont appris qu'il faut
faire quelque chose vite je trouve que
c'est un esprit allemand
practique qu'il faut prendre quelque
chose mais mais il ne prend pas en
compte le fait qu'il faut avoir aussi
l'approche stratégique pour autonomie
stratégique ou souveraineté stratégique
qu'on a qu'on a aussi conseillers dans
la sortie du compas qu'on a adopté
stratégique en fait vous dites
finalement c'est la Real politique à
l'allemande Olaf schols la pratique même
si c'est un chancelier social-démocrate
qui est d'ailleurs en coalition avec des
vers aussi votre partie il a décidé donc
sans la France de ce boucler qui serait
moins cher et plus efficace et ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec cette cette
approche et plus rapide
directement sur le coup parce que je
pense que les raisons elles sont plus
structurelles je crois que ce sujet
manque de clarté
tous les groupes ici vont vous parler de
l'autonomie stratégique je vais vous
avouer que moi j'ai jamais compris cette
notion de l'autonomie stratégique on
peut pas être dans le temps être
autonome moi j'ai plaidé et d'ailleurs
le groupe est une anime le groupe écolo
est unanime là-dessus je suis pour une
émancipation stratégique des Européens
au sein de l'OTAN donc ne plus déposer
des États ne sont pas obligés toujours
les mêmes que c'est des États-Unis et
moi j'ai en mémoire la période trempe et
le recentrage des États-Unis sur
eux-mêmes et sur leur propre intérêts et
sur leur relation avec la Chine
aujourd'hui il se trouve que 30 n'est
pas en responsabilité on a Biden et que
la question de la guerre se passe en
Europe donc nos intérêts sont les mêmes
que ceux des États-Unis c'est pas obligé
que ça dure et puis la démocratie
américaine avait engendré Trump on n'est
pas à l'abri demain que de la même chose
donc moi je plaide je pense que la santé
la guerre en Ukraine serait déjà
terminée au profit pour profiter je
n'ose pas Europe de la défense et autant
m'isoler face différemment je pense que
tant qu'on n'a pas construit une Europe
de la défense on va rester dans l'OTAN
mais je pense qu'on a la responsabilité
entre européen de construire notre
propre vision stratégique et conseils
mon site et qu'on hésite pas à dire de
manière collective et forte quand on a
des accords stratégiques longtemps on
n'est pas obligé d'être toujours suiveur
et en parallèle faire l'intégration
industrielle faire des politiques
communes et construire l'Europe de la
défense alors est-ce que un jour
finalement sur cette ce soir parce que
Emmanuel Macron il va vite en bozone et
il oppose la construction de l'Europe de
la défense à la question de l'OTAN je
pense que c'est de nature à brusquer un
certain nombre de partenaires européens
qui ont se trompentisme trop autant je
pense qu'il faut faire les deux en même
temps que les phasé c'est ça l'approche
écologiste
communiste en Europe sont atlantistes et
ont signés pour ce bouclier allemand
sauf la Pologne votre pays n'a pas
choisi son camp on peut dire les 27
est-ce qu'ils sont pas loupés ici le
coche d’enfin concrétisé la mise en
oeuvre une politique industrielle de
défense commune on doit on doit
développer notre défense mais aussi un
para aussi en compagnie avec notre
partenaire transatlantique parce que
dans seulement là maintenant les
États-Unis ils n'ont aucune intérêt à
l'Union européenne ils ont tourné vers
pacifique et maintenant il faut notre
travail et toutes tous les pays
l'ancienne communiste qui savent très
bien qui sont le prochain d'être attaqué
qui sont prochaines d'être pris ils
savent que la seule protection de ce
moment vient des États-Unis et il ne
faut pas être né pour pour le laisser
comment je refuse qu'on pose comme
donner du débat et à la proposition
allemande qui vise à nous protéger et la
française qui vise à ne pas les un
système de défense vise à nos défenses
la question qui se pose la question de
la souveraineté l'argent il est l'argent
il est pas il est pas magique on
achètera soit américain soit occupé
les deux systèmes vont nous protéger et
les deux vont coûter la question qui se
pose c'est laquelle de notre
souveraineté européenne est-ce qu'on
veut profiter de cette situation pour
donner un coup de pouce à la
construction de l'Europe de la défense
et de faire européen pour nous protéger
sans remettre en cause notre alliance
avec les États-Unis dans l'auto et je
l'ai dit ça te phase là aujourd'hui elle
est indispensable tous ceux qui vous
diront le contraire sont soit naïf soit
nous menthe et donc je pense que
l'Allemagne participe à rater un coach
important pour l'avènement du Nord de la
Défense et de notre souveraineté
nous au sein de l'Union européenne aussi
une réalité oui mais on a une industrie
de la défense européenne
une meilleure intégration et plus grande
coopération peut nous permettre de
produire les matériels qui nous permet
de nous défendre c'est c'est la question
de lever la poule si on si on intègre
pas nos moyens la Commission elle-même
dit que si on intégré nos moyens avec
les mêmes dépenses on peut pour la même
pour la même qualité on pourrait
économiser entre 25 et 100 milliards ça
veut dire que si on regarde le même
niveau de dépense on pourrait être
beaucoup mieux protégé
cette semaine que elle allait financer
dans le Fond Européen de la défense pour
un montant de 832 millions d'euros 41
projets en commun
41 projets en commun ça a l'air d'être
un début de réponse commune mais encore
faut-il là encore qu'il soit
interopérable que que les que les
matériaux marchent ensemble en fait que
le matériel de défense marche ensemble
et c'est pas vraiment on s'entraîne
ensemble même hein mais oui ça c'est
nécessaire mais faut se souvenir que la
Croatie a acheter le rafales et
maintenant les pilotes craintes sont
entraînés par par des pilotes français
et il y a cette il y a cette coopération
qui est vraiment qui est vraiment
nécessaire qui est vraiment grande
il ne faut pas éviter la coopération
l'entraînement commun aussi à
reconnaître les menace quand même et
aussi dialoguer un peu plus parce que
moi comme président de notre groupe
j'organise les réunions à côté de notre
pays à la frontière la semaine dernière
j'ai organisé une conférence split sur
et on a on a traité des sujets de le
ménage
avec une Balken oxydants
occidentaux de la frontière et 50 km de
Split et aussi on a fait la même
conférence à Séville on va faire la même
conférence à Paris pour tout notre
député pour pour comprendre quelles sont
on a ce qu'elles sont quelle est la
priorité pour nos collègues et pour nos
pays c'est 41 projets communs de
recherche et développement donc financés
par l'Union européenne c'est un début de
quelque chose justement oui mais ça
suffit pas il faut qu'on consomme
européen je vais vous le dire tel que je
le pense on a un cadre non contraignant
qui encadre l'exportation des armes moi
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent qu'on
doit pas armer les dictateurs qui
utilisent les armes contre leur
population mais tant qu'on n'aura pas
intégré au niveau européen l'industrie
française de la défense ne rentabilisera
pas ses lignes que avec le marché
français c'est la même chose pour
l'industrie italienne c'est la même
chose pour l'industrie des autres États
européens en intégrant mieux on fait des
économies d'échelle on se défend mieux
les États-Unis
faire les VRP des dictateurs dans le
monde pour permettre à nos tenir parce
que quand on commande
sa sécurité et maintenant ils sont tous
les pays faillite qui dépendent Wagner
qui dépend des Russes de la technologie
de ancienne Union soviétique et qui
aussi ont les idées
complètement d'accord mais en quoi
construire la défense européenne sur
quelque chose de naïf moi je pense que
c'est quelque chose de très pragmatique
pour notre sécurité pour la sécurité de
la région en quoi c'est naïve de vouloir
construire notre souveraineté à travers
la justement de l'Europe de la défense
ça serait notre question finale très
rapidement prochain sommet de l'OTAN à
Vilnius les 11 et 12 juillet prochain
qu'est-ce que vous en attendez
précisément au regard de cette défense
européenne au sein à côté en parallèle
de l'OTAN
je pense que cette semaine va aussi
souligner que le temps est nécessaire
que de vivre qu'il faut vraiment le
prendre au sérieux parce qu'il y avait
des idées des propos avant un peu plus
avant cette agression et que cette
partenariat entre un pays qui
dépend vraiment de l'OTAN de d'être
encouragé par par cette coopération
aussi avec nos partenaires
transatlantiques
pour souligner l'importance et le besoin
d'autant dans la séquence d'aujourd'hui
moi ce que j'attends c'est que la
fermeté nécessaire du point de vue
militaire et de l'automne soit
suffisamment forte mais que le volet
diplomatique et de recherche de la paix
pour que la guerre s'arrête parce que
mon idéal moi c'est la paix c'est pas
qu'on soit armé pour faire la guerre
d'abord parce que les populations
locales souffrent et que
la réussite en état doté et qu'il faut
qu'on trouve une porte de sortie
diplomatique de cette affaire donc il
faut qu'on marche sur les deux jambes
militaire activité extrême au niveau
diplomatique pour arriver à ses feux et
à une fin de cette guerre et ce seront
les mots de la fin merci merci à tous
les deux en d'être venu débattre sur
notre plateau merci à nos
téléspectateurs de nous avoir suivis
vous restez bien sûr sur nos deux
antennes pour plus d'informations
[Musique]